welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm joined by michael
judkins who is
a senior manager at free search michael
works within the marketing digital and
e-commerce sector
he's been working in recruitment for
over eight years and is currently
managing a team of seven
previous to this uh michael worked at
michael page
for four years but for the last four
years has been part of a grown
recruitment business
in free search michael thanks for
joining me on this uh
sunny friday yeah no worries good to be
here it's uh
yeah i think we're the only two people
inside currently everyone else is taking
calls outside or doing some work in the
garden with the uh
cardboard box over the laptop type thing
yeah it's just me and you
delight to have you on here obviously uh
you you got recommended highly
recommended by uh
some colleagues that they'd love to hear
you you was
yeah obviously they recommended you to
be one of the best recruiters they've
worked with
um yeah someone in my team andy so i
don't know if that was a
he was trying to stitch me up or
hopefully he genuinely uh
yeah believes the comments exactly yeah
so look we're always like to start on
this is uh
how did uh michael enter the world of
recruitment let's start there
yeah so i um i graduated
in 2010 um and was looking for a job
um and i thought i wanted to get into
marketing i'd done business management
at uni
and the plan was you know i'd always
been interested by brands and
marketing um and i felt like that was
the career you know career path for me
um but a few people kind of kept saying
to me you know
family friends um just saying have you
thought about sales if you thought about
going down that route you're really good
with people
um you know and i guess you know
they knew that i had aspirations to do
well and
you know some financial mobile so just
kind of talk to me about that route and
i ended up getting a job
um locally for a family friend which was
a kind of sales support role
that lasted six months um before i
wanted to move on to something a bit
bigger that was i
left you know left home kind of come
back home to um
work and i just did that for six months
but then joined a
beer company um called molten cores um
so i was out in north london
going around to pubs knocking on doors
selling beer um
which was yeah interesting yeah yeah
yeah
very interesting um particularly when i
was in tottenham i'm an arsenal fan
so uh yeah going around tottenham and
trying to flog them uh
vlogging some beer was uh yeah
interesting they asked the football team
and you're kind of like
backing out the door um so i did that
for about a year but
part of my frustrations with that was
that it was
it was a field sales role so i had no no
day-to-day kind of
team interaction you know we spoke a lot
on the phone with colleagues and our
team meetings were
you know once every couple of months and
it was great because the industry is a
really interesting industry and it kind
of got quite close to marketing because
i was working with some really good
brands you know
um but i missed i felt well i felt like
i was missing some of that interaction
and i guess i wanted a head office role
so i applied for a number of different
positions after about a year started
applying and one of the businesses that
i
um saw advertising lots of sales roles
were um
michael page so i wanted to go down this
kind of national account
head office sales group where you would
work with groceries like sainsbury's et
cetera so
i applied for a number of roles there
and i got a call from um someone in
their sales team
uh michael page a recruiter um and
she um you know she spoke to me had a
really good conversation she basically
read me
i didn't know that at the time that was
that and uh yeah
kind of you know said she'd be in touch
then about
a couple of days later i got a call from
a chap called joe curtis who you
who you know and who you've had on the
podcast before
um and yeah he called me up and
you know in true joe fashion just you
know didn't necessarily kind of say
what that was about but started having a
chat with me um
you know asked around my motivations etc
what i wanted
uh yeah and at the very end said i've
got a good job for you you know
have you thought about recruitment uh
and
yeah i guess that was that was 2012
january 20 well i was december 2011
um so i came in met with him and met
with the director there and yeah as i
guess i say the rest is
the rest is history so uh yeah he he
kind of
yeah he he flipped me um we went to the
same uni not that i knew him i'm quite
glad i
probably didn't know him but yeah not
that dude but he kind of got me sold on
the fact that we had a common league
because uh yeah he uh yeah i went and
i went and met him met the team at the
business and got a really good deal and
i guess
you know at that time like i say part of
my motivations for moving on was i
wanted something that was
um you know team based i'm a sociable
person i like the interaction
you know of of colleagues which is you
know probably why this time is quite
interesting for me
um but yeah you know and they offered
that as well as a solid career
progression an opportunity to
i guess be in charge of you know well
your own destiny to some extent i guess
that was that was the sales pitch at the
time from joe but you know um
we'll get on to that later yeah that was
that was
yeah so that's how i got into it i love
that really interesting and um
i didn't know you worked for you was in
uh joe's team or worked for joe
um i've worked for yeah i've worked for
joe for yeah
what eight year wow my whole my
um okay well so look so just just so
everyone understands so you joined
michael page and you've worked there for
just over four years
i think right on linkedin yeah yeah
that's about right four and a half years
yeah and then after that uh period uh
you then joined
uh free search and you've been there for
the last four and a half years right so
let's talk about michael page for a
second so what sector did you go into
so joe and um
another another director called chris
were setting up the digital team there
um at the time and joe had a background
in recruiting for consumer businesses so
naturally
he wanted me to do the digital marketing
um
and um all those sorts of roles within
that so at michael page it was just the
digital team
um from scratch yeah just starting out
from scratch it was me
and me joe and chris and we were you
know i guess kind of nine you know nine
years ago
you know the roles that are very common
today and the most common roles that we
recruit were the ones that were you know
just starting to hire out businesses
were starting to separate marketing and
digital
they were trying to hire talent into
those areas um
and the business saw an opportunity to
have a dedicated team within in that
space
um and the relationships that joe had
and chris had were all in
what we classified as consumer so that's
retail travel local hospitality
type businesses um what was you what was
your first year like always interested
in first year so you
joined this big brand you're starting
something from scratch you're
leveraging joe's and chris's
relationship reputation what what was
the first year like
uh interesting yeah it's a real it's
it's always a real shock to the system i
think you
you you have a perception of i didn't
know much about recruitment i had one
mate um
who worked in recruitment for um
after uni and he worked for s3 he worked
for huxley and you know in birmingham
and
before i joined michael page i called
him and you know he said yeah i think
you'll be good but just be you know be
warned it's you know it's tough and
yeah you just don't really know what
you're getting yourself into you think
you're calling people about jobs and you
think you
you know that's it but there's so much
more to it than that
and um yeah it was a real learning curve
um
because i guess you know on the one hand
you're trying to learn
about the job but you know the
environment as well that you're in is a
very sociable one i went from having you
know no interaction with colleagues to
be you know to kind of socializing and
being you know out
you know two three times a week um you
know with people maybe more so
you know it's a very sociable you know
it was a very sociable place back then
so
you know you had to kind of learn how to
balance that and then the social stuff
as well and everything going on
but um you know what i really i really
enjoyed it it suited me
um you know at that time we were you
know it was a kind of 12
you know it was 11 hour 12 hour day kind
of place you know you were in a you know
you started at eight you finished at
seven that was just standard
so that was a bit of a shock but yeah i
enjoyed it
well what was your what was the biggest
challenge for you in year one do you
think
i think understanding or trying to
understand
that um that the people were
different and that
you know not everyone's motivators for
moving jobs
you know are the same um and actually
you need to adapt your approach you know
based on that individual
and just working my head around perhaps
the psychology you know behind
recruitment
is the biggest yeah i still think that's
the biggest challenge for anyone
entering it anyway
um you know would you what do you mean
by
more about the fact that you are dealing
with people who have the ability to
change their mind
okay the drop of the hat and actually
you know
the psychology behind why they are um
looking for a job and what they want
from that job and you know what's
important to them
and actually is that really important to
them or do i need to dig further and
further and get into the detail
um you know the amount of times that i
you know i kind of remember going you
know to joe and chris
right yeah kendall wants x y and z then
actually you know
a few questions from them and i was like
left there going
ah okay i don't really know you know and
i i guess you know that's good it's a
learning curve but
it's just getting into that their
mindset i think is probably the biggest
challenge is that you're not
you know you might have a perception on
a job and why you think it's great but
that doesn't necessarily mean the person
you're talking to does too
um and that's a really big thing to
overcome i think for a lot of people
because it's hard
you know sometimes it doesn't make in
your mind it doesn't make sense
yeah you can come frustrated quite
easily to say well
you know why don't you want this job or
you know why isn't that enough you know
for you
and i guess that's just yeah that's just
yeah it's it's yeah that i definitely
agree with that i think uh
at the early days every candidate you
speak to is the perfect candidate for
for the job and
uh yeah and um i can't remember who i
got this advice from or i might have
read it someone that really stuck early
on that really helped me is um
ask the questions that you don't hear
the answer to and yeah
because sometimes you just want to get
through that reg sheet
it's like right joe i've got this
banging candidate and then
yeah it's just such a at the beginning
you've got to get good at just
swallowing things like yeah you need to
go and find this out
i'm laughing because yeah joe you know
um hopefully he'll listen to this i
expect him to but he'll
you know his classic phrase to me was
like stop burying your head in the sand
he was like you know you've got all
these good qualities and it comes to the
difficult question and you just
you know you're just not asking it you
just because i was scared of the answer
yeah
the answer that's what it is yeah and i
you know it's one of the things you know
for me
um i i'm a real people pleaser i like
people to like me
so i don't want you know i i don't want
to ask
questions that i know will provide will
perhaps provoke a difficult conversation
because
in my head that candidate or client then
won't like me and therefore
i will take that personally or i used to
you know yeah it's one of the things you
have to learn to deal with yeah
but yeah i'm i'm like that in in life i
like to you know i like to please people
as much as i can and you know
that's great but it's also you know in
this job can be a bit of a you know it
can be a bit of a downfall
um you know at times you have to i've
had to learn how to
deal with that and approach that in a
different way and have a different
mindset about that but
yeah early on joe was yeah stop bearing
your head in the fans it was a remember
that
yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely there's
many uh
many phrases i remember um what what did
you end up billing in the first year do
you
remember
oh god i want to say it was about 80ish
yeah so okay yeah so i think i joined in
january
from standing start and a new desk and
yeah we did yeah i think i did about 80s
which was probably
it was okay there i mean you know
michael page's model
meant i didn't really see you know you
know see anything for that but
i guess in terms of performance on the
whole it wasn't it wasn't awful but it
certainly it wasn't great i didn't you
know didn't change the world in my first
year of recruitment
but it's starting from scratch i think
that that's fair so
so so then so then let's just segue a
bit here so
was there for another three years and
from what i saw by the time you left you
was a manager
yeah is that right and did you stay
within that so did you continue to build
that desk
um in that market why she's there okay
so that basically yeah i just followed
that built up and then
became to manage to consume a team in
you know by the end of it was managing
four people
how long did it take to start managing a
team
three and a half years so three years
three and a half years
in and then you start managing yeah yeah
okay cool
right so let's just break this down a
bit so firstly just out of interest
because i think um i think um
in terms of this current period i think
this has encouraged
a lot of people to use the overused word
pivot or whatever right which could mean
that you end up
i don't know doing different types of
job titles that you normally do or
whatever right but
just quickly out of your experience
during that period like how long
how long did it take you to build out
that market would you say that consumer
market to have a real solid
bank of clients that enable you to build
a decent
amount per year like how long did it say
before you like you know what i'm really
pleased with where this market obviously
can always improve but how long do you
reckon that journey took
two years yeah that's interesting yeah
i i i'm you know whenever i meet anyone
new you know you know early on their
career and you know maybe graduates
trying to think about getting to
recruitment i i'll always talk about
18 months to two years as a as a
timeline i think
especially if they're doing a new market
or they're building something
um and they haven't got any experience
in it i
yeah i'm a big believer in that you need
to play a bit of the long game
and i didn't know that back then but i
guess you you only know
what you know and having done it for a
number of years and helped people
hopefully build markets in the last you
know more so in the last four
years since joining three search um yeah
i i would say it was probably two years
i remember thinking throughout the first
year oh yeah it's clicking
but it wasn't clicking um
i just i just had a good run or
something of you know a good month or so
um but then you know next month i'd
still make some of the same mistakes so
yeah i i guess two years to really kind
of feel like i had a
good level of clients and that i could
rely on for work and i'd
helped build that up and and leveraged
off the the size of the
business you know it was slightly
different for three search and michael
pages i was a
you know fortunate guest from michael
page in the size um
to leverage off some of the
relationships they've had and that is
good and bad
um you know for you know for going out
to market
uh but i was gonna say how how much did
it help you having a brand like michael
page when you picked up the phone did
that actually
help you cut through the noise yeah i
think early on uh yeah i think
i i i really do believe that recruitment
has changed quite a lot in the kind of
time that i've been doing it but i think
early on
yeah that brand you know particularly
marketing recruitment were
you know they were they were a go-to and
so we leveraged off the marketing
recruitment business and did digital
marketing and just
kind of yeah went in dovetailed and and
were able to
to you know benefit off the back of that
um
i don't know how much that would help
now i i guess it's one of those people
at least people know who they are
um and early on in research when i
joined
that that just wasn't it just wasn't the
case so you had to find something else
you weren't
you know you weren't winning work off a
brand um
which is actually the i think you know
now again you know four years on i think
you know
we win work off our relationships and
our ability and and
you know that's that's that's what's
really good to see
for us and how we've grown that business
but i didn't have that then i won work a
lot of work off the brand
interesting and just just to sort of
find a couple of things before you move
on to
free search i guess what i was keen to
get your thoughts
on michael is um sort of knowing what
you know now
what advice would you give yourself
early on in building out a market on the
client side that you think
would have really helped you because i
think it's the client side that's the
most difficult right been in this
reputation
and obviously yeah you'd like to think
typically you have more access to
candidates and have more conversations
there but
so what what advice do you think and
give yourself or to those at the
beginning or early stages of building
out a market that you think would really
benefit the client side that would have
helped you
yeah i think um
the first thing i would say is around
organization and that might seem kind of
a bit of a weird one to start with but i
guess
from day one or you know early on you
are contacting clients who
don't know who you are and i think you
need a way of tracking that
um and i was very poor at that to start
off with
um and i think a lot of recruiters are
you just you know just you just chase
the money a bit don't you just chase
you chase the next c and and you go from
client to client and you and you don't
track who you've had some interaction
with
and yeah i guess in by tracking it
you're then
giving yourself an opportunity to go
back to that individual whether that be
one month two months six months later
and have another touch point with them
and another interaction with them
and then again another you know and and
hopefully you know through
you know enough times of them seeing
your name or your brand or however
you know enough interactions with you
you will then start to see
something from that but you know i still
say that that is a long that's a longer
term gain
but if you're not doing that early on
and you only start doing it after 18
months you've missed 18 months of
opportunity because you've not tracked
it
and i just think like imagine how big
like you know if i had this spreadsheet
of everyone i've spoken to on the client
side from since i started recruitment to
now
i'd be amazing you just go through and
and and i tried to spoke to speak to
them
constantly throughout that time i
probably wouldn't need to do any form of
cold business it would you know it
and and it's about just believing that
you know you do repeat that and you do
follow up and and you make sure you
follow up so that's when i talk about
organization it's like organizing
yourself
to give you the best ability and in some
respects there is a little bit of an
automation element there but
just trying to build relationships and
then identify the ones where you're
going to make money from that so you've
got your then
you know you're organized and then you
start to get you know fights or start
people start to interact with you and
then it's
you know making the most of those um and
if you do that from early on
i think you put yourself in a really
good position in that 18 months
two years time yeah have a system you
don't have some sort of system right
yeah
you're completely right because i think
yeah you need to if i turn around to you
and go right microwave the next
three months what what clients are you
trying to get into or whatever like you
need to have some sort of system and i
agree whenever
i had some big wins it didn't come it
rarely comes in that first
contact right i could catch it the right
time and go michael i've got this
candidate
blah blah blah how often do you be to
seeing them or whatever that that might
happen
but guarantee you're gonna get way more
wins off the third fourth
fifth seventh time that you try and
speak to them and it's that seventh time
that breakthrough and it ends up then
being one of your best accounts that
yeah
so if you don't have a system that you
can follow follow
that's gonna ensure that you have those
touch points and you don't try and
implement that in your day
yeah in your weekly cadence yeah i think
that's great advice love that
and you've got to see everyone as an
opportunity i think like
again it's so easy to get a knock back
and then go well okay they're not gonna
work with me
yeah and actually there are people that
i work with now who you know
eight years ago probably did not i don't
you don't you forget about it you forget
who's knocked you back eight years ago
but yeah some of my best friends now i'm
sure that i tried to
call back then and they were you know
that because i've been doing the same
market for the
eight years you know a lot of the same
people um yeah i'm sure they did you
know i'm sure they did but
once they say yes you forget about all
the you know you forget about the
knockback so it's just
yeah like seeing that opportunity but
that is a longer term
mindset and i think that's really hard
when you aid when you first start
recruitment
or if you're early on in your
recruitment career to see that because
ultimately sometimes you feel the
pressure of having to deliver against
say
the targets or the you know or the kpis
you know depending on where you are
you know actually you're working week to
week you're not working longer term so
you forget about all that stuff because
you just need to get a certain
you know number or something to to yeah
what you feel like to
yeah very true um so did you did you
want to go into management
yeah always oh you always wanted to go
into management okay yeah i was um
yeah i yeah i knew quite early on that
was a that was something i was keen to
do
okay interesting um well what i'd like
to do then
let's i want to talk to you about your
journey of research
but two things first one is
obviously now you've been in the real
startup environment which is one of the
questions that i have
but before that work for michael page
and now you have something to compare it
to
although obviously it's only two
companies but two completely different
environments
someone what would you say the main in
your perspective
pros and cons or working for a big
corporate big brand would you say in
recruitment
um yeah i i think about this a lot
i it's interesting i work for a business
founded by people from michael page and
so
you know when people talk to me about my
time there
i you know i always speak very highly of
it um i had four and a half very good
years i met
you know my now and you know my my now
bosses there um
who i've worked with for eight years you
know some indirectly
you know my face indirectly um you know
somewhere in other teams
um and the relationships and the people
and the contacts and the network i've
got from people who worked in that
business
has really benefited me going somewhere
smaller
and i can say the same for the three
directors is that you know that
that environment and that ability you
know that the sizes it just gives you an
opportunity
to create and build contacts because
there's so many people there not all of
them end up staying in recruitment
agency side a lot of them go in-house
a lot of them go and do different things
um so
that is definitely a plus i think the
training there was
you know i i would say having met and
interviewed people from
you know different businesses um the
training there is excellent
was excellent at that time um i think it
gives you a really good grounding
um and structure to how to approach this
job um
especially with kind of like process
management and and
you know candidate management and client
management um
and i still go back and revert back to a
lot of stuff that i learned
in my in my training there um
so that definitely is a is a pro to work
i guess for me the cons are
i feel like they lose
people because of um
their you know i've seen a lot of people
from there go and start their own thing
or do their own thing and i think
unfortunately sometimes their structure
and the way that they approach
you know the the career there and how it
needs you know and how
how you progress means that they they
lim they limit people
who have this ability to be creative in
how they want to do a management job or
run their business
um and it's that that i think is a
really
it's a real shame because if i look
around at some of the companies that
have been founded by people from michael
page
there's some really good recruitment
companies out there and imagine if they
kept that talent surely that you know
that would be you know that would be a
real bonus to them and
um yeah i think that for me is you know
that's that's
that's a big shame about that you know
working in that environment i think um
i think what you said there's really
interesting actually the first point i
don't think anyone's actually said that
before because i've had different people
work for s3 and all these things
but i think that's such a great point
and i think that's something that i can
really relate to that
not everyone thinks about right that
when you work for these big companies
or just just companies in general it's
so important to
have an emphasis on relationships that
you're building in the forwards of your
business
because you have no idea how they might
be able to help you in the future and
that isn't the only thing you have in
your mind but
like yeah really anyone listening that's
in their business right now
make sure that you're building great
relationships with the business owner if
you can with the people around you
because you never know
when that person could when you could i
don't know you might be able to help
each other right and i love that you
brought that up because
especially if you think yeah the types
of people that
encouraged that it created to start
these businesses and these
entrepreneurial people
especially if you're working for these
big brands make sure that you're
networking internally and make sure that
you're good at relations i think that's
such a great point
to make
you know it's kind of same as a
candidate thing you know people talk
about your candidate is king and
treating them with respect because you
don't know where they're going to end up
like i i apply the same logic to it
internally
yeah you see a lot of people with you
know big ego you know
you know in our environment you know
it's natural you're gonna get that and
they just rub people up the wrong way
and then as soon as they need a favor
from i don't know someone else they used
to work with
they're not gonna get that because you
know they're perceptional but you know
this is where it came in handy you've
been wanting to be liked by everyone
exactly this is it there is something to
be said about that but yeah
so okay cool so let's talk about your
your time at free search completely
different environment as you said but
obviously the familiarity of the the the
faces and the people that obviously work
for joe that's one of the founders of
research but what i wanted to ask you
besides the sort of going into a startup
environment should be completely
different
like from your perspective what do you
think
out of these three it could be
individually or all three of them what
what sort of qualities or things did
they demonstrate as
leaders that you think really compelled
you to be like you know what
i'm confident or i'm actually really
excited or i actually want to put my
careers not my careers in their hands
but you know what i mean take the leap
with them like what
leadership quality do you think they
demonstrated that resonated with you
that made you think you know what i'm up
for this let's do it what what did you
what yeah
it wasn't yeah i mean it was it was
certainly a risk at the time
you know what i thought i thought it was
anyway um
you know to leave that environment that
safe secure environment where you know
what your next job is going to be you
know your next three or four jobs in you
know in that business and you know i was
in a good place
you know i was ready to be you know
young to be a manager you know i seem to
be
someone who was doing well um and to
leave that all
behind a lot of people were like why and
i guess it had to be you know
the right thing and i joke
and joe will laugh but um he he always
says it took a while
and it did it probably took about six to
nine months i mean they
yeah they're around for about a year and
a bit before i joined
but even early on he started the
conversations
i guess for me what works for them is
they are
three very different individuals with
all very different attributes but if you
put them together
it makes for a good business and i
always say this so
um you know charlie does
you know charlie who i report into is
you know he does a lot of
the people management stuff and you know
for me he is a great leader
i've learned a lot from him um i felt
like he would move my management career
on
um and yeah his his ability to build
relationships and
like you know both internally and
externally and
you know he is classic of that point
that he is you know part of the
a lot of the work we've had at research
has come from his relationship to
michael page both internally and
externally and he's carried them through
um but he's also someone that people
want to work for
and he treats people with respect
whether they you know with us for
you know a month or two or you know five
years he you know treats them all with
the same respect so
for me working for him um you know was
was
was going to be a real um was part of
the reason i joined
um and uh you know from
joe i i've known for a long time he only
managed me for
probably nine months to a year you know
he would admit that he
he wasn't you know that wasn't his
long-term career path to manage people
he felt i think he felt like he needed
to do it in a business like michael page
because he thought that that was the
next route
to the next job um but you know
admittedly he probably said that you
know he wasn't
you know that's not his his strength his
strength is going out and
you know winning work and you know
his ability to kind of sell and
influence is for me
still you know he's still probably the
best person i've ever worked with in
that regard when it comes to
winning work and winning good quality
work
um he yeah so i thought you know i could
definitely learn something from him if
i'm going to go to such a young business
and and and you know and grow then yeah
that ability would be great
um and andy andy was like the shining
star at michael page so
i didn't yeah i didn't work for him um i
worked with yeah
i don't want to make his ego any bigger
um he will laugh um
he thinks he's the best football player
in the business and he's certainly not
but
he was um he was uh yeah he was he was
our you know he was like the
yeah he was the kind of like one of the
youngest managers i saw him you know he
joined about a year before me he was
always just that one step ahead of
michael page you know he
built you know incredible amount of
money when he was there
um and i guess for me
um having seen his work ethic and how
much he would care and put into that
and then you know that was working for
michael page what would you do it was
his own business
and you know he he cares he works so
hard um
yeah he really you know he's really
passionate about making us the best
marketing recruitment comp digital
marketing marketing recruitment in
in london now for now but you know
hopefully you know further afield as
as as we grow um and that you know that
for me is really important working with
people who believe it and i'm not saying
the other two don't
of course not but yeah you tie all those
three things together and i think you've
got a really good recipe for success
um and i think it works because they are
three very different people
um but that's you know
i think sometimes a challenge with like
a small business if you have one person
it can be quite it can be quite tough
and they can just leverage off
each other's you know strengths and yeah
you know five six years on that they're
really doing that i think
um you know they know what they're good
at and not and so they let that person
take
charge and leave yeah yeah that's that's
kind of why yeah no i think that's
really interesting i think
ultimately what you're saying there is
yeah like that you really recognize a
real opportunity for
you to grow right and and for you to
continue developing these things and i
think that's really common for a lot of
people
because especially when you do well and
obviously i'm sure there's other parts
you could have gone down but
it's not it can be difficult in
recruitment when you feel like
you're not at the top just like billings
wise but when you sort of at the top and
i write who else can i learn from who
else is inspiring me and
that can be quite difficult sometimes
right so i think yeah
i love the fact that you really
recognize an opportunity
to grow so when when you joined this
business obviously it was an environment
that you had
you you was an environment which you
were used to you knew what you needed to
do
all these things right so um obviously
work to free search i think obviously we
said before we started this
joined as a manager but obviously wasn't
managing anyone until six months in
so just straight billing um i guess what
i wanted to ask
you is firstly like what
happened in the early days of you
joining free search or
yeah that you didn't expect and i guess
what i'm trying to get at michael is
what was the most difficult part about
transitioning from
a big sort of corporate like michael
page although obviously you work for joe
and these things
for you to adapt to this complete new
environment where i think you said what
there's
five or six six of you when you joined
what
what was the hardest part around that
because i think there'll be a lot of
people listening that
may have to go through that transition
or thinking about it that
that's a part that gets them quite
nervous so what was what was the most
challenging part about adapting to this
new
staff environment would you say yeah i i
guess so
i talked a lot about the social side of
michael page and the size of it
um you know that interaction with so
many different people and then going to
a business where you had three directors
and then two
you know two employees in research and a
couple of other people in the office
was was a real shift um i'm not saying
that
you know i didn't enjoy that but you
know early on
in those those times we we kind of went
to work to work and
went home because if two people or three
people had something on then
you just you can't get a kind of group
together to you know to go to the pub or
catch up or do anything so
that was quite a big adjustment um early
on
um and now that we're at a size you know
that we are we've kind of you know
we've got that you know social element
back but for a good six months to a year
it was quite a different environment
um so getting my head around that um and
trying to and it you know it worked well
for me i lived outside of london you
know i didn't necessarily want to be in
the you know kind of pub
every night um but you know it's just
getting your mind around that um i think
um you know and then following on from
that point
you have so many people that can kind of
help out and support in a big business
whereas in a company like that at that
size
you kind of got to go and do it yourself
um which
you know i enjoy you know i guess
getting stuck in and being like right
i'm you know kind of
like i say i went from managing a team
before to not managing for six months
and it was quite refreshing just to kind
of
do some recruitment but do all the stuff
with involved no one was doing anything
you know and
i kind of sound spoiled here but you
know what no one was uploading his cv
yeah it was all real kind of like right
this is it you know
linkedin phone and that was it was kind
of like back to basics and i
i you know i really enjoyed that but you
have to be prepared for that um
especially if you're coming from a
bigger environment um
there is an element where you i
say i wouldn't want to say like a lack
of a lack of structure or organization
but you know
everyone's learning you know the
business was what 18 months or so when i
joined
and you know even in the last you know
i've been there four years
you know we're still learning we're
still learning how to do things we're
still learning what processes we like
and what we don't like
and i think for a lot of people that's
really hard
to adjust to because things will change
and direction will change and
what was you know um you know something
we
you know i don't know the way we went
about business development early on is
very different from now
yeah um and you have to you have to
adapt and you have to kind of roll with
that a little bit and
not become hung up and say well you said
this you know and i guess in bigger
businesses you kind of have that all set
out and you kind of know what you're
doing and it's all
you know it's all quite rigid um you
need that ability to
adapt and be flexible in a in a smaller
environment yeah
that's a really good point expect a bit
more chaos
yeah yeah yeah i really like that and
it's especially when you come from a big
company they would have had processes
and everything instilled and but i think
that that's where the growth can come
from as well
right and and obviously the the learning
um so what i wanted to talk to you about
michael was
i get loads of questions around you here
all the time
billing manager is the most difficult
role in recruitment right so i'm
assuming that
for the time that you have been there
you've always been billing and your
management
responsibilities have grown so
why don't we talk about um as we come to
the second half of this why don't we
talk about michael's journey in being a
better leader learning from the people
around you being a manager
so when you start you could refer to
michael page if you wanted to as well
but
so as you started so i'm assuming that
you build for out
you being a manager yeah yeah yeah so
let's just talk about this for a second
like firstly
what was your what was the thing that
you really had to get your head around
or what you really had to master or
challenge that you had to overcome um as
a being the manager that has really
helped you what was the the real
challenge or thing that you really had
to overcome firstly would you say
yeah i guess it's for me it's mainly
around time so
you know if you're a billing manager you
know before
you add however many hours a week depend
on you know
how many hours you work um to do all
this work and you're in
you're in charge of your own destiny and
you go out there you try and win work
you place work
um and then all of a sudden you have
someone else
to help out and and and advise and
particularly if they're
relatively early on in in their career
that's really time consuming it you know
it takes a lot of effort they have a lot
of questions naturally so
because the job isn't you know the job's
not an easy one to get your head around
regardless of what people think about it
and the perception from the outside is
it's a complex job which has many moving
parts and that takes a lot of
explanation
the other thing that is challenging
about recruitment is it happens
it happens live like a candidate a
conversation with a candidate or client
there and then happens there and then
and if you don't handle that or manage
that in the right way
at that point then something that may
end up in
you know something going wrong further
down the line or you know and and i
guess
you know i talk to a lot of friends and
there are lots of other jobs where you
know they would say well do you need to
deal with that now
but in recruitment i often feel like
there's a lot of stuff that you do
there's certain things you don't
and you learn that as you get you know
as you as you get more experience
actually that isn't urgent and
prioritization and they are all the
things that help
but the biggest challenge i you know i
find and found kind of especially early
on is just that time and around
having to do what is expected of you
billings wise
but also helping someone out and early
on perhaps not seeing any reward for
that as well that you know that yeah
that is a challenge there's this gray
area typically when you transition into
a manager or you're early on
in that you haven't got that formula
right so you're
suffering on your billing your problem
your your consultant or whoever is
working for you might not necessarily be
up and running yeah
and you yeah you know you kind of have
this period where it's like right well
you know what we've done for the last
six months but i've been working so hard
i've been trying to do all these things
it's that's so true that isn't it
because it's like right
we all want career progression right if
that's progressing
in terms of um earnings or progressing
responsibilities or whatever so yeah
you take this progression opportunity do
it right that might even come with a
salary increase or whatever but and then
there's a lot of suffering that comes
with it as well right as you just as you
said so time is something that always
comes up
so why don't we talk about um it could
be you during kobe that might change but
like what does the non-negotiable
billing manager michael
have what is your weekly non-negotiables
because it seems like what always ends
up happening is that
you have some sort of system management
process that you've now got locked in no
doubt it could improve sometimes or
whatever but you've got some sort of
process dialed in that could be every
monday at this time they can chat to me
or whatever but what what's your
what what's become your sort of system
management system would you say
that helps you get a grasp of time
yeah um i
so we all have i guess you know it has
changed recently because of obviously
everything going on
um in some respect for the better i
found like
you know being in the office and being
visible you are
you're there and available and people
can see if you're on the phone
or or not and therefore if you're not
they will ask you a question or they
want your time and actually
part of the benefit of being you know
the last few months of working in this
environment is
they haven't been able to see that so
they you know the team haven't perhaps
in some instances
contacted me as as as much not not not
everyone but you know
they've not contacted me as much because
they probably think that
i'm busy but i guess in the new world is
a lot of the time
you're kind of booked out in half an
hour hour slots at the moment um
it doesn't really allow for that
flexibility because you kind of have to
book something in
don't know you can't see the other
person so you don't know what they're
doing
you book something in so that has meant
that i think
most recently um i have had some more
time to prioritize
um on my own stuff and and crack on with
my own you know
my own work but when i was in the office
um we have a team meeting once a week
at the you know kind of the start of the
week which is kind of a chance for
everyone to talk about you know updates
on
on stuff and then individually i would
catch up with them on a monday so i
block out monday morning
monday morning is my team time so talk
to them
how was last week review set up um this
week
and yeah let them go with it any
questions
just quickly what are the cool ques what
are the core things that you want to
know as a manager or find out from your
team is it
right what obviously we don't have to go
into like kpis or whatever but like what
are the things that you want to see as a
manager that
that makes you feel right i'm excited
with what the team
could produce this week is it like
talking about what what their pipeline
looks like is it talking about
what their plans for business
development this week what are the
typical things that you're looking out
for as a manager would you say
yeah probably a bit of everything but i
guess for me what's important is
okay you know i do say you've got five
jobs my first point of call is to run
through those jobs
um and just see where where we're at
with them
because once i know that information and
i i will then dig deeper
you know like i said block out this
whole morning to talk to you know five
seven you know
it will be seven people um now it's like
i block out that whole morning to get
into the detail so i want to know
where they're up through a process how
close to the fee they are with that
process and actually
you know is that candidate going to
accept that job if offered
and i'll do that you know with every
role and then yeah i guess following
that and getting an update we can then
work on okay what are the objectives or
targets for this week
because i can set them before but then
you know
that might be before i get into the
detail but then i'll change it because i
need to know what they're up to with
other things
um it's easy just to you know it's easy
just to say you know just to say that
um so that's the first thing um and then
um
yeah i guess business development would
be the second thing like what do you
know what are your plans for the week
in business development you know how are
you you know where are you going to win
work from where's that job coming from
and as long as i know that information
i make a note of it somewhere and that
is what i found that works for me is
that i'll make a note
um and that i will record that um
somewhere so that i can then check up
later on in the week say wednesday uh
midweek just checking how you're getting
on against that and then again at the
end of the week
and try and have some follow-up system
and i think that that's the important
bit for me
around time it's like you set them up
you ask them the questions they tell you
what they're going to do
and then you have that regular
checkpoint and like we're all guilty in
recruitment i'm not doing the follow-up
but
if you could be strict on that that for
me then enables me to have more time to
go away and do it so they know
unless it's a okay candice about to you
know turn down an offer
that actually our catch-ups are kind of
roughly scheduled in
sorry um sorry can you hear me now sorry
i can mate sorry that last comment just
couldn't hear it
sorry it's okay um what i was gonna say
and do you have an offense so there's
like an accountability piece basically
yeah do you have anything at the end of
the week where you
sort of have dedicated team time where
it's like a
right guys what we achieved this week or
i don't know do anything like that or is
it just more of a
or not really no i i know i know a lot
of businesses do it's kind of like that
friday
like you know wrap-up type of thing i
often find friday and recruitment the
day that you
get like loads of stuff just happens
because every client in canada is like
right it's friday
it's kind of their day to to catch up on
stuff and that's like right i need to
put these people into interviews
etc so i was trying friday to be pretty
mad um
there is an argument i guess for it
my view is if i do that again on the
following monday as long as i check in
and review the week and you know
they are then accountable for that week
and we've got better at this since being
in
in in um in lockdown and
we've got a better system or we believe
we've got a better system for holding
people accountable for that
which is interesting um that's what we
worked on early on as i write
you know we've got an opportunity here
to kind of look at some stuff
and actually how are we going to hold
people accountable for for things
um so we we do it we do it on a monday
but now that makes sense yeah there's an
argument to say friday as well i just
yeah don't know if people always want to
talk about that on a friday
that makes sense so so the next thing
about management
um michael that i'd love to get your
thoughts on so i've always spoken to
a lot of billing managers leaders that
have sort of shared how important it is
to really
get under the skin and understand of the
sort of drivers
for your team and no doubt this helps
the accountability piece right or when
you're recognizing that well actually
this person isn't
stepping up the mark or isn't doing what
they said it was what what things do i
need to push or what things do i need to
encourage that i know
is going to resonate with them right so
and to sort of tie this in with today
i think one of the most common things
that i keep hearing is um
businesses and not just recruitment but
managers and leaders
um really making sure or trying to
impact the motivation of their team
in this remote world right so i think
this sort of ties in quite nicely that
actually even in
this not this this current world
understanding your teams and individual
motivations is so important
right how have you gone about getting
better at that
how important is it to you like what
what what have you had to do as
a manager to get better at understanding
people's motivations and do you think
it's important
yeah absolutely think it's important
although i'd probably say early on i
didn't recognize how important it was
because again you kind of just look
like well you know you're in recruitment
because
you know um you want to make some money
or or
i guess it's easy to go i'm in it for
this reason so surely they
they must relate to that otherwise yeah
yeah
yeah and actually people are different
and motivators are different and
yeah i think you know the for me the key
thing to being a good manager is to
recognize that you have a team of
individuals and not everyone wants to be
managed in the same way and not everyone
likes that
um you know there are certain things
that you you you kind of have consistent
across the team
um you know maybe the way that you team
meetings etc but
you know if you need to bring up a point
with someone um
some people don't feel comfortable about
that being in a public forum and and
that would actually demotivate them
whereas other people don't mind that
because they you know they don't mind
being
you know they want to then prove other
people wrong so i guess it's just not
working out and understanding
and getting into detail so um yeah i've
done some stuff i've actually um
done a few like uh i call you know like
questionnaires around motivators with
the team to get into it and so i've i've
separately got like
those motivators um what sort of
questions would you ask if that mummy
asked well it's not it no it wasn't it
wasn't me it was a question um
put me on the spot here it was a
training course that i went on
um and a lady running it
um talked about um a questionnaire and
she wanted to understand why we what
motivated us as managers
yeah so she was a management training
course so we did that
and then she said how useful would this
be to do with your team
yeah it would be great like let's go and
do it so the next week i was like
right here you go and they're a bit like
why am i filling out this leader's like
50 questions where you tick what
motivates you and it's like the random
question is like
you have a car like would you buy a car
or a house or like
like that kind of gets into like your
the reasons you know the reasons
you know how you approach stuff and yeah
i did that and i it was really
interesting
um you know and there's lots of things
about like people wanting to be
recognized like being recognized is
really important to them so it's not
about the power status it's about the
recognition for the role
you know they don't want to you know
they don't want to be seen to be the
bright lights top below that's not for
them actually
someone just saying well done on i don't
know well done on
you know finding that candidate is
enough for them to say yeah i'm going to
carry on
yeah it really motivates me um and i
yeah i believe in all that stuff i think
it's really important having had you
know
um different managers who have been able
to motivate me in
in the right way and some who haven't um
i think it's really important but i
probably didn't recognize that early on
in my management career
how important it was but it was only
until i looked at how i wanted to be
motivated
that i was unable to think actually how
do my do i know how my team wants to be
motivated and i guess the answer at the
time was no
so i feel like i've got that
understanding now and then when i talk
to them individually
i can then you know lean on those
motivators in order to hopefully get the
most out of them
um but that is challenging in this time
because you know there is a
it's a very different environment and
you are you know that
there's an element of it's not an
element it's all about trust at the
moment
um and you have to trust your people and
you have to trust that they're
working hard and yeah i think you know
early on
i was unsure as to you know not to doubt
the people of my team at all but i was
just unsure of
whether i could personally deal with
that um because
i've always been someone who i thought
needed to be present
and be in the office like i said i live
you know live outside of london got
young family
um you know i've always said well the
job you know needs me to be there
it needs me to be president so because i
can get them motivated and do this and
actually what i've seen from
you know those who work during this time
is you know honestly like it's been
great like they've shown me that i can
capable of trusting them that i don't
need to be there so it wasn't necessary
on them it wasn't that i didn't trust
them i perhaps just didn't trust
i didn't trust myself to believe that
they could do it and so it's been good
for me
really good that and yeah i guess i know
that now by working with them and
understanding what motivates them that
hopefully i can still get the most out
of them
in this environment yeah and then i i
think that's such a really good honest
sort of overview of
your experience of that and what does
king just get your
thoughts on was i guess this might tie
into
sort of what you look for when you're
adding to your team but what what do you
think
are the sort of common habits or key
characteristics you typically see
in in high performers or the great
recruiters that you work with either at
michael page for research what are the
typical things that
come up for you that no doubt you end up
looking for in people but
what are the common habits or traits do
you see in real
top performing recruiters do you think
yeah i don't want to say work ethic
because this is
what everyone always says but there is
no stephen let's
let's make sure everyone knows work
ethic is paramount
yeah yeah i i can't i can't deny that
and
you know i think for me having you know
when i look back and i think about the
people that
you know i've seen there and and are up
there you know
they do put the extra work in um
but that's out of choice not because
they have to they want to do it and i
guess that's probably more the attribute
you're looking for
that willingness to do it and that
willingness to understand that
actually at times you might need to
invest more of your own time in order to
get a result
so it's not someone who can just work
hard it's someone who understands that
yeah i want to do that in order
to get something from this um
so you know i always think that that is
key but how you
you know how you measure that interview
stage or how you look for that is very
difficult um because everyone no one's
going to sit there in front of you and
say
you know i'm not a hard worker or that i
leave you know i'm going to let you know
i'm just gonna you know do my you know
do do what i need to do and and kind of
head off no one will ever say that yeah
i guess you need to get into kind of
other questions around how they would
approach stuff and and kind of stuff in
their life in order to try and work that
out but
that one's a key one for me um
i guess the other one is around
um you know this
again you talk about it but it's
resilience it is that ability to
to understand that maybe it's not
personal and that you
you know this happens in the job and and
yeah you you get knocked back but you
keep going and
and it kind of ties into the work ethic
i guess but yeah that ability to take
those things take the rough of the
smooth and and
you know get over it quickly and move on
um
and just say well okay i've got an
opportunity to you know kind of just
okay i've got an opportunity to fill
that job you know i'm gonna go and fill
it
um and making sure that yeah you can
you can you can stick to that i guess is
is yeah so
you know they're the two things that i
often see are in the you know the high
performance
um what do you and then on the flip side
like what what do you think of some of
the common
maybe traits or habits or just things
that you see
in recruiters that prevent them from
maximizing their potential do you think
um for me a lot of it's around mindset
now and i get i wouldn't have said that
three or four years ago
because i didn't perhaps really see how
important that was
and it ties into the other two it's
about this willingness or mindset to do
it but
you know for me those those people that
perhaps kind of uh yeah you know
struggling to move on often it can be
someone else's fault
it can be the candidate's fault or the
client's fault um
you know that's the reason it's gotten
wrong they haven't looked at themselves
and gone right what do
you know if something goes wrong with a
process i'll sit there i'll try and take
some time to review it and work out what
i did
firstly what i did wrong in order for
that process to have gone down
because there will be some there will be
something responsible responsibility and
kind of
yeah it might not be you it might not be
solely you it might be you know there
might be different elements but you know
firstly you've got to look at that
um and i think too often in this job
it's easy just to be like oh that
crime's rubbish or that candidate you
know
that candidate you know you whatever
it's just like
it's easy to blame it's yeah it's it's
easy to blame because you've got people
involved who aren't you so it's easy to
pass the blame
and that for me is the main thing that
holds people back because
if you if you can if you can put the
work in and and you get your you know
ethic right and you can kind of overcome
you know the challenges of the job and
and you know the ups and downs and you
know there are you know it's you know no
denying that
and you can yeah get your mind in the
right place and
you know i think typically people you
know will do well
um the other thing that i like to talk
about and i guess
again this is quite hard but is around
this kind of ability to be able to
talk to people and and have some form of
your level of emotional intelligence
i think it's really important for our
job um
there are some very good recruiters out
there who i've seen
but i think sometimes they lack that
ability to move it on because
they get a brief they can fill a rock
and that's fine if you've got that
constant flow of jobs and you've got a
constitutive candidate
but if you're up against it and you need
to try and go out there and win and
build relationships you need to have
that ability to be able to
yeah build a relationship with people
and that's been a really
that's been a really key thing for me
since joining researchers you know
talked about earlier about
you know relying on the brand well we
didn't have we don't have that so it's
about relying on our relationship
building ability and actually
you know um the people that i've seen to
be most successful are the ones who can
build those relationships that last
a long time and and and that sometimes
does hold people back and i don't always
know what you can do about that because
i think you can change mindset but i
don't always know if you can change
the ability you know someone's ability
to interact with someone and how they go
about that
um in a lot of ways you're kind of over
you're one of those people or you're not
um so i don't know if that's helpful for
people because it's like
well
i think it ties him with your first
point right if i'm someone that has
listened to this and going well actually
i think this coronavirus period has
taught me that actually my relationships
aren't as solid as i thought i was or
actually
yeah it did only speak to me when i had
the cv right i think the first part
the mindset part will give you the best
chance of improving the second part
because if you're someone that's willing
to take accountability and
responsibility to go actually
i actually i i thought i was really
consultative but actually i i'm actually
quite be what can be quite transactional
um i think it's
actually having being able to realize
that and have the humility to try and
work on it
is something that can give you a better
chance of becoming better at it
um does that mean you're going to then
be as good as the person that might have
it naturally maybe not but i think
you firstly got to be someone that's
willing to go you know what
i need to work on that right and
so yeah that's really interesting
actually what and so as we come to
the end here what what what's been the
most difficult part for you then
over the last couple of months would you
say i think it's always important for
people to know that the challenges
they're facing is
they're not alone in facing them i think
if i could direct you potentially but
you don't have to talk about this one of
the
most common things that i keep getting
messages around is business development
of course
hearings that clients are putting up
jobs or you're putting up jobs and
you're getting 300 plus applications
doesn't necessarily mean the quality is
still there but still there's a lot more
noise
around well actually we can probably
feel this directly or whatever but
ultimately what i keep hearing is that
we're going to be in a client short
market and a candidate long market right
some would argue that but overall that's
the sort of general consensus that i
keep hearing but
i think it's the the business
development in a slightly different
world how have you been approaching that
something you want to talk about but
what have you found difficult over the
last couple of months would you say yeah
i'll talk about
i'll talk about bd and business
development and then i'll talk about um
yeah maybe maybe something else that
i've you know kind of found um
you know challenging so i think on on
the business development front yeah look
you know naturally
it's the current climber really does you
said it just a minute ago
opens up your eyes to whether or not you
have a relationship with that client or
not and have you
previously shown a value add to that
client
um is that more than just placing jobs
yeah absolutely
you know we yeah i've had experiences
and people in the past who have placed
jobs and then they get a new one
and you know the client may go somewhere
else but we successfully or someone
successfully placed the job and you're
thinking hang on a minute what better
measurement for success and recruitment
is there than placing someone in your
team
but of their experience on how you
interacted with them
you know the offer process you know
whatever it may be may not have been you
know as good as it needs to be in the
current climate and
i think that's not just the current
climate i think that's the last couple
of years like
customer experience is you know we you
know we've done a lot on this recently
but
for me that has to be that has to be at
the forefront of um
you know you're you know in recruitment
now you have to be very good at it
you know 10 years ago i don't believe
you did now you have to be
because it's a world where people can
talk and people will will easily you
know call you out for that online or
whatever it may be so you have to make
sure that's good
and they expect a lot and you need to be
able to provide that and so yeah it's
real
eye opener when you're kind of like well
i recruited this role for you you know
six months ago you've got that and
they're like yeah we're just going to do
it direct and you're right right well
have i not shown the value add of the
last six seven placements that i've made
um and you know sometimes it is that
sometimes it's you know
you know there is i guess a real reason
why they perhaps wouldn't want to work
with you at the moment and you kind of
have to understand that
um i keep saying to myself and the team
you know as long as
you know if they do use a recruiter
you're the one that they go to that's
the best position you can currently put
yourself in
you know if if you know you obviously
you know you want who want the work on
now but if they're going to go direct
but they said they will work with you if
they use an agency
that you know that that is that is a win
at the moment whereas you know that
wasn't a win six months ago i guess
you're looking at that as a win because
the reality is just because they're
getting an extra
200 applications doesn't mean they're
going to fill that job any easier
we don't need to go into the reasons why
or why that is the case but we know that
might not be the case um so yeah it has
been a challenge but
i guess you know to the point i made i
am very fortunate that i joined a
business that has tried to build its
you know brand on relationships and so
as a result
we we've had a steady flow of work you
know not not may you know
kind of time but the last two months we
have had a steady flow of work from
people who
can see the value add and not saying
it's not tough out there we're certainly
doing more business development than we
were
six months ago but we've got a better
structure for it now and that's the
thing that i've taken
we've taken away from it it's like we've
improved in all these areas
so you know we should hopefully come out
of the back of this better and we've got
a better system for chasing work we're
holding
people more accountable for that we're
going to get everyone to do it you know
you know earlier on in their kind of
time in the business and and
and you know constantly do it and have a
formula and a follow-up to
in order to do that so um yeah it's
you know business development is hard
but the way that we've looked at it is
it's you know that's probably not going
to change so we need to have a better
recipe for doing it
and if we can continue to do that
hopefully we will then pick up the work
um
so yeah i think you know that that that
is
that's one of the challenges and then i
guess the other challenges i think
you know we mentioned this just before
we started kind of properly talking is
just around
how good you need to be at managing a
process at the moment and how into the
detail you need to be
and i don't feel like the current
climate allows you to
cut corners um you know when you're
talking to a candidate and you just
really need to strip it back to basics
i think when you said that for me i just
wanted to clarify that
that just simply means there can't be
any question marks or
not you cut corners as the process or
whether it's just
sorry yeah no no i know i know what
you're saying but that's what came up
for me it's like
right now you have to be like
99 sure that this person
wants this job or for the right reasons
or whatever right so it's like you have
to be asking those questions
here the answer to you have to yeah turn
over every
every stone and so yeah as you said
you've really had to dig into your
process
there's an extra layer you need to go
into and you need to yeah you need to be
able to manage that and you need to try
and
account for the fact that things could
change and yeah it's it's
it's an interesting well we're in at the
moment and things keep changing and
yeah you know some of it's out of our
control but there is still a lot in our
control
um and we need to be aware of that and
again you know have that mindset like we
can influence this we can do something
about it and not just blame the fact
that
you know something's going on that means
that you know well it's tough to recruit
at the moment because of xyz yes it is
tough well you know
actually i think in some respects you
know
the good recruiters out there will come
will come out better and
you know businesses will recognize who
is good at you know at recruiting
because
you know this environment means you have
to perform well
um and it'll be interesting to see in
six months to a year who's
who still who's still around yeah
absolutely
i i genuinely think that because yeah
you're going to have to you're going to
have to offer something different and go
above and beyond
um yeah so that's your candidate or
client experience and and your delivery
needs to be good as well
yeah no great point so as we as we
finish here what
how so how just as we're talking about
that like how do you see the land laying
in recruitment
in the next six to 12 months like what i
don't know what's
we don't know what it's gonna look like
but what's in you've been in the game
for a while
what what do you think could be some of
the interesting things that could happen
in our industry do you think
um so one one one is that point i just
made i think
um that you will yeah i think
a lot of people are going to look at
this and work out if they want to do
this job
first and foremost so you know we we are
an industry full of people that have
fallen into it
that perhaps didn't choose it as a
career path and i guess when when it
gets tough
i always find you know that actually
that's when you see a lot of people
leaving it
so i think you will probably work out
who wants to do it as well not who's
good enough to do it but who actually
wants to do it and who wants to be here
and and
yeah wants to you know play the long
game
um so i think now i think there'll be a
lot of turnarounds
people changing career or doing
something different if they can um
i think you'll see a lot of people start
up on their own
uh because a maybe where they're working
you know might mean they have to but
also because
i think it's an opportunity you know
you've got to look at this and see
there's an opportunity for someone to be
able to perhaps
do that if they feel like they you know
if they feel like they are good and they
are better than the competition
then you know it is an opportunity for
someone to go out there and do that
and i appreciate right now you might be
like well that's such a big risk but
i expect things to pick up i hope that
things will pick up i have to believe
that otherwise you know
kind of i'd be sat here then just being
like down about it you know i need to
believe
that the recruitment market will pick up
and i guess hopefully
if you set yourself up in the right way
six months time you might be in a
position where you really benefit from
that but you need to be able to you know
so i think
i think they're the two things i will
see uh or that we that we may see
sorry not we'll see maybe i don't know
yeah i think i've seen so no i think
yeah i think uh
i think people's why is definitely going
to be tested during this period
to to get up every day and work from
their dining room table or whatever when
there's no one around that camaraderie
which is obviously a big part as to what
can help us get going and
i think also yeah loads of conversations
that i've been having that
sort of this period has really shown
that actually this is a company i'm
really proud to work
for or the opposite right and i'm sure
this field is into your world when
you're
trying to work out why people want to
leave their job and what i'm hearing a
lot of when i'm working with recruiters
is well actually
they're turning around and going look
i've been on furlough since april and
i've had one call from the director
right so
i think you're complete i think that's
definitely going to be interesting
for sure and i think how that positively
impacts things is that hopefully
the people that do stay wanna be in
recruitment which
hopefully means that the standards they
have for themselves of delivering
recruitment and for their clients and
customer experience hopefully
should should raise the bar a bit
because if you're a [ __ ] recruiter and
just fling out cvs
are you gonna i don't know are you gonna
survive i'd highly doubt it
yeah we might be wrong you know i agree
yeah maybe maybe not i just think yeah
we probably you know we've had a good
it's been a you know relatively good run
of it in recent times
and yeah i guess when it's when it gets
tough you just you see some of the
cracks emerge but um yeah it's really
interesting to see how businesses have
approached this whole thing and some of
some from what i hear of absolutely you
know nailed it and
obviously i'm biased but you know i hope
that people who work for us feel like
you know on the whole we have we've done
a good job of communicating and keeping
in touch with people and actually
you know that talk about that level of
like togetherness you know i've
certainly seen that
particularly amongst my team but also
across the business
and there are others who you hear
stories about and you know you obviously
speak to people and know people in
recruitment and yeah it does sound like
some people have
unfortunately not and i guess hopefully
what that means is there's some really
you know you know i'm looking at us for
the future there's some good talent out
there to like
talk to and potentially join us like
that's you know that's
great for us business yeah they've other
businesses of you know
upset their best best performers well
yeah you know
and we're hoping that we can still
continue to grow then you know why
wouldn't we
why wouldn't we understand the
conversation with them so yeah with
fingers crossed you know there'll be
there'll be some
we'll see some of that um love that well
um
look michael been a pleasure love your
mindset
and uh thanks for coming on thank you
for having me